your daughter Ruby yes yes it's began
acting quite early and well you put her
just for fun you put her in a web swell
when she was like around 7 7 months old
I kind of realized like oh wow
Ruby's like really good at like sitting
and like and looking really cute so I
fed you around here
so it's you
so I decided like why don't we like make
like a show like based around her as a
detective a detective
yeah was she at the time she was around
7 months old at the time and and you
know his based on that you remember that
showed The Mentalist
yeah yeah we called it baby Mentalist
and and she was the star of this
detective show all right I think we have
a quick clip from this web series you
made called paid evangelist during your
daughter let's take a look
so what crime family are you working for
[Music]
oh that's baby Mentalist there's no need
to dr. Jones looks just like you nah man
see he's got a neck tattoo that says
RICO mice is me go me damn it is right
what do you think baby Mentalist
I agree it can't be him
[Applause]